Feast Your Eyes Upon these light
transport simulation algorithms Ray
tracers if you will these enable us to
simulate the path of millions of light
rays bouncing in a scene and create
absolutely beautiful photorealistic
images H but there is a huge problem
what is the problem dear fellow Scholars
this is two-minute papers with Dr car
now look at the previous technique here
is the problem noise my goodness so much
noise this would take quite a bit of
more time to get rid of and now have a
look at the new technique oh these
images are so much cleaner are they
usable well we have noise filtering
algorithms for light transport
simulations are they any good well let's
have a look together let's plug in the
previous technique into a noise
filtering algorithm and the input has
these walking light blobs are they gone
now unfortunately not this is supposed
to remove noise and not fix these blobs
so let's see what happens with the new
technique and oh my I already see that
we have less noise and after filtering
Bingo love it not perfect but so much
better so let's have a closer look look
at what just happened here is a
comparison with path tracing this is one
of the first algorithms you learn on
your light transport class it can barely
do anything on this notoriously
difficult scene mmis this is marginal
multiple important sampling now this is
so much better however with this we also
get lots of noise this is the rester
technique that you just saw with the
blobs this is from 202 too and gives us
less noise that is good however look the
specular highlights on the teapot are
different they do not match the true
simulation it does not give us the image
we are looking for and now look at the
new technique oh yes less noise and it
is correct at the same time this was a
particularly good case for the new
technique but even on a selection of
other scenes it performs really well
better than its predecessors a solid
step forward loving it and we are not
done yet not even close I have a bunch
of incredible new papers on R tracing
for you to Marvel at when creating games
and Virtual Worlds we often find
ourselves having 3D geometry that is not
too detailed but we would like to make
it look a bit more interesting slapping
a texture on it kind of works but it is
still very flat and not very exciting
now we would like this geometry to stay
simple and quick to render easy to store
but at the same time to appear to be a
lot more detailed look so much better
this technique is called displacement
mapping and it can make a really simple
piece of geometry come alive in your
games and Virtual Worlds however it is
not new not new at all it goes back 30
years possibly even longer so what is
interesting here in this new paper well
two things one hold on to your papers
fellow Scholars because it can do all
this up to 11 times faster than previous
techniques H now is the point where I
immediately think that potentially by
leaning more heavily on memory so maybe
faster but at the cost of using more
memory however I was very surprised to
find out that this was not only not the
case but it also requires three times
less memory that is incredible two it
takes a possibly fractional level of
detail parameter that is very cool you
see level of detail helps you save
Resources by rendering a course version
of a piece of geometry and add details
to it only as we get closer this is when
we would see them after all however this
often happens in steps where you can
often see from detail level zero to one
or 1 to two this object suddenly looks
like this object there is a pop however
look with a fractional level of detail
parameter we can make it pop a little
less and these transitions will look
more continuous note that other
techniques can do this too but this this
is one more tool in our toolkit so cool
I could also not resist showing you this
realtime technique that can simulate a
bit of light transport for instance it
can do indirect illumination or color
bleeding this is the bleeding effect of
light as it bounces around multiple
diffused surfaces and it is a beautiful
phenomenon in nature but unfortunately
less so in many Virtual Worlds because
it is so slow and expensive to compute
but not here this technique can pull off
limited light transport but in real time
and the implementation of it is
available on Shader toy where you can
try it right now and even look at the
code or modify it and we are still not
done yet this new technique can create
this gorgeous material by shooting more
than two million Rays at it per second
and it uses less than 20 megabytes of
memory that is almost nothing for a
geometry of this detail this is a
sigraph Asia paper which is perhaps the
Olympic gold medal of computer Graphics
research written by a single author
Bravo Shinji and I would also like to
show you this these gorgeous light
transport simulations are done with
luxcore render this is a free fully
open- source renderer with with many
Advanced algorithms I used to contribute
to this project wrote some code in it
and enjoyed every minute of it it is an
amazing system still used by many many
people and they need your help if you
smart fellow Scholars could contribute
that would be absolutely amazing I have
a link for you in the video description
by the way if you wish to learn how to
understand and write these amazing light
simulation program prams I have a
completely free Master level course on
it for you where we build up such a
system together from absolutely nothing
it is completely free for all of you
fellow Scholars no strings attached if
you watch it you will see the world
differently have fun if you're looking
for inexpensive Cloud gpus for AI Lambda
now offers the best prices in the world
for GPU Cloud compute no commitments or
negoti ation required just sign up and
launch an instance and hold on to your
papers because with the Lambda GPU Cloud
you can now get on demand h100 instances
for just1 199 per hour yes $1 199 and
they are one of the first Cloud
providers to offer publicly available on
demand h100 XS did I mention they also
offer persistent storage so join
research fees at organizations like
apple MIT and ctech in using Lambda
Cloud instances workstations or servers
make sure to go to lamb.com
slapers to sign up for one of their
amazing GPU instances today